we got big news ladies and gentlemen
from Business Insider Jack tahera 21
arrested in connection with the Pentagon
document leak attorney general Merrick
Garland the suspected Pentagon leaker
was arrested Tuesday by federal agents
in Dighton Massachusetts Merrick Garland
identified the suspect as Jack tahera 21
a Guardsman specializing in intelligence
tahera allegedly shared highly
classified documents about the Ukraine
war online
so they're treating this guy like you
know Enemy Number One Public Enemy
Number One but uh there's a few
important things just to bring up right
away as to why the story matters one the
mainstream media lied to Joe Biden lied
three it seems like Russia is actively
winning the war and four actually there
are U.S Special Forces on the ground
this is now confirmed it's not
speculation and uh well you know
everything you thought about the war
you've been lied to about and I can just
assume that anybody listening to the
show is not surprised at all because I
don't know been here done that yeah I
mean they've been on the ground since
2014 and this latest action by the
Federal Bureau of Investigations and the
doj going after the Whistleblower
treating him like a terrorist by the way
the way that they captured him just just
is just absolutely crazy when this guy
is coming forward providing documents
that by the way the corporate media was
gaslighting us telling us we're real oh
the these files don't exist and they
said oh no they do exist but this one
portion about the number of Ukrainian
dead troops is definitely manipulated
here out of all those documents and then
they told us oh it was definitely the
Russians that released this information
and today we found out that exactly was
not true at all and there's a lot of big
things in these documents they were out
on Discord for a number of weeks no one
really paid attention to them but now
after all the gaslighting after all the
propaganda all the lies it looks like
these documents are legit and they do
speak to a lot of the bigger things that
are happening in Ukraine that we should
have a real serious conversation about
Sir Ian I cut you off oh Senator Joe
manchin tweeted out I don't know if you
guys saw this eight hours ago in my
lifetime I've never seen the United
States of America in a more just war and
it's a video and people are like
Congress didn't declare war bro like
this guy's a senator and he still lives
in Virginia that's that's really
concerned yeah we're going to make sure
he's not a senator for much longer
granted he's got a few more years left
and something to do about that because
you can't recall Senators but that guy's
a scumbag yeah I mean we used to respect
Daniel Ellsberg and the Pentagon papers
and muckrakers and whistleblowers in
this country and now we're doing the
exact opposite of that with the
Washington Post and New York Times being
accused here working with bellincott
specifically hunting down this
whistleblower just a few days ago six
days ago Reuters was saying that
according to Anonymous U.S officials
ever heard that one before you hear it
all the time when they try to tell you a
bunch of Lies according to U.S Anonymous
officials Russia was behind this leak
again why are they continuing to lie why
do we believe them the only real way
that we could get truth in this country
is through whistleblowers so for them to
go after this guy so hard really shows
you how they're trying to hide the
bigger truths here because you know if
people really knew what the government
was doing if if everything was
Declassified they would be pissed and
people know that and that's why they try
to suppress the story as much as they
did that's true too but the big thing
here is that in the documents the reason
the media comes out and says these
documents appear to be real but may have
been manipulated that is to say that
someone took real documents and altered
the numbers the reason why they had to
lie is that the documents show that
Russia has only suffered around 17 000
casualties
despite the fact the media has been
reporting 200 000 and that Ukraine has
suffered around seventy thousand which
is now that we know who this guy is now
that we see that it's just some dude who
got arrested not a Russian uh oh looks
like Russia's winning the war in Ukraine
we also have dumping more and more money
into it and and we are losing not that I
want to be over there and we have Kirby
coming out telling the Press not to
cover it who's Kirby uh John Kirby he's
like a spokesperson
I mean just a shocking National Security
spokesperson yeah that's the guy you're
you're talking about here specifically
coming out yeah don't report on this and
again the Pentagon also said don't do it
yeah yeah Pentagon also sent notices to
social media companies saying don't do
this Elon Musk commented on this saying
you know if there's one way uh not to
bring attention to a story this is not
the way to do it I'm paraphrasing he
didn't say it in the exact way but but
this is this is a big story and
highlights a lot of Ukrainian young men
that are dying that are passing away and
I think we have to start asking the
question why what is the goal here what
is the purpose here what's really going
on here why are we being told
everything's peachy everything's the
Russians are going to be defeated any
moment now you hear it on the television
all the time history repeats Russia
usually has a very bad way of starting
Wars but the longer the wars continue
historically the Russians have a huge
amount of Manpower that they throw into
these wars and usually are more
successful and are able to defeat their
victories the longer a war goes on so so
to to one prolong this conflict in the
history in the Afghanistan of Europe
that is Ukraine is absolutely crazy in
in the first way even if you are a pro
Ukraine but second of all how many
innocent young men you're you're
destroying entire population of young
men that are being butchered and
slaughtered for what the profit of of
the military industrial complex I used
to think that but uh you guys know about
that that royal family that got all
inbred I think they're called the
Habsburg is that was that it the
Habsburg you mean the the British royal
family is that them no it's like a
European royal family and they're all
inbred and the Habsburg family was it
the Habsburg family most royal families
well no for sure for sure but uh it got
me thinking as you're talking about this
like why are we overseas and you know I
thought about 1913 you know the start of
the Federal Reserve some authoritarian
strong-minded individuals are you know
meeting on Jekyll Island and they're
like we're going to create a centralized
banking system
and then you know they have kids who
have kids who have kids and then you had
you know Dr Ron Paul in the show just
come right out and say that there was a
revolution when the government murdered
its President John F Kennedy and it's
like well okay then and I'm just
thinking about it and I'm like that's
like the kid of the Federal Reserve
people and now what we're dealing with
is like the Habsburg Offspring which is
our current military industrial complex
like their two inbred and deformed to
properly function in terms of
international policy so while China is
basically taking over while they're
doing negotiations with Saudi Arabia and
Brazil to get off the US dollar
our habsburg-esque military industrial
complexes like we must conquer Ukraine
and you're like for what dude it is the
habsburgs they're known for the
distinctive Habsburg jaw it's h-a-b-s
and they were it's like
like if you look at pictures of the
Habsburg jaw you'll see they were like
for being inbred but these people aren't
inbred I think they know what they're
doing because they always do it and and
when it comes to losing when it comes to
Human Sacrifice these people don't care
if the United States loses these people
don't care if Ukraine loses Ukraine has
been used by many corrupted politicians
by many internationalists by many
globalists there's a reason BlackRock
and Goldman Sachs has all the contracts
right now in Ukraine there's there's a
reason they don't care look what
happened in Libya look what happened in
Afghanistan look what happened in Iraq
these wars aren't meant to be won we
have to think from the perspective of
these people don't care about you they
don't care about the United States they
don't care about how we look to the rest
of the world they care about their
contracts they care about their money
they care about their blood sacrifice
which essentially they're doing here
when we could have had peace we could
have had negotiations we could have had
this conflict ended last year in April
but no the Western leaders got involved
flew into Ukraine and specifically made
sure that this conflict was prolonged
which is absolutely insane which just
absolutely crazy and now there's U.S
Special Forces operating inside of
Ukraine with Mission critical functions
14 U.S troops what are they doing
exactly there we don't know 50 UK
Special Forces 15 French Special Forces
and 17 lot fee and Special Forces over
100 U.S Personnel in Ukraine right now
and uh how many about a hundred U.S
Personnel in Ukraine right now those are
the estimates according to these
documents that came out there and uh
even you know Donald Trump came out and
said during the Syrian War he killed a
whole bunch of Russians because the
Russians were fighting there how many
troops are we losing are we even going
to be documenting how many U.S forces or
U.S soldiers I mean there's people who
volunteer there but officially this
changes the game as well Trump also you
know responded to Tucker essentially
acknowledging that Nordstrom was
perpetrated by us he said it in a in a
kind of he alluded to it in a very
sneaky way he said it he was like I
don't want to make us look Tucker asked
him who who blew up the pipeline he's
like well I don't to make our side look
back but it definitely wasn't the
Russians uh but again Trump's also
analysis of Putin and XI and Kim uh was
also uh pretty interesting that
interview was also the Dynamics between
Tucker and Trump that's also something
people are really looking into as well
that are that was really eye-opening but
what does any of this have to do with my
beer
that's a good point Tim what does it it
might get a little more expensive maybe
it'll get cheaper who's to sell would we
have Jessica Kelly on the show the other
day and he was mentioning that Bud Light
this story was the first time his
neighbors actually asked him about
politics and and the reason I bring that
up is I'm just like okay so basically us
has Personnel on the ground we are
actively at war with Russia without a
declaration from Congress we've dumped a
hundred plus billion dollars into this
Russia wants to send nuclear weapons to
Belarus China is getting Brazil and
other countries off the U.S dollar and
uh well the U.S Empire is all coming
crashing down or whatever it is you want
to call it and the only thing that
animates people is
otherwise what I think about this
transparency concept we talk a lot about
transparency it's a big part of minds
and why the code is free and open source
is because you know this guy Jack that
this 21 year old that is arrested for
for leaking the documents you actually
talked about with Joe Rogan on on his
show this was before his name came out
and it's like you posed a question like
if every piece of data was released
would it even be a good thing like it
could very well just cause massive war
so
I don't know if it's always good to leak
every doc you know no not every document
but we need vastly more transparency
than we have I'm curious how how
specific did he go through any kind of
like a legitimate whistleblower process
for that no just put them on Discord you
put them on this so that's that's kind
of asking for back yeah but there's no
such thing as a legitimate whistleblower
process well I mean they're they're
there's there is so there is and then
and then they get ignored or shut down
or told to shut up just like William
Benny has fair enough no no I'm not
saying that he should have like gone and
asked permission I'm saying that if you
you know in terms of redacting names and
you know in certain circumstances there
there is like a due diligence process
that can make sense to be a little bit
careful yes I understand what you're
saying I I feel like all of these
platitudes are just Comforts for those
who want the rules for themselves that
is to say if the United States does
something like Barack Obama blows up a
kid who's gonna hold them accountable
they get away with it but if any other
country does it oh you better believe
they're going to come out and cite all
of the rules and read every single one
of them so when I when I when I think of
whistleblowers they say well he should
have gone through the process right the
process by which he goes to a commanding
officer and says they're lying about
this and this needs to go to the public
and they say thank you for bringing us
to our attention have a nice day the the
process and the rules are intended to
stop people from telling the American
people what's actually going on and how
they're lying cheating and stealing and
destroying our country it also tells the
world but I mean go ahead oh I mean all
the Russian people know now too that's
part of they knew though they knew
though you think in Russia they really
believe 200 000 soldiers had been killed
they lived there but I don't think they
knew that there were 100 American
Russians actually came out with a very
interesting statement when these
documents first came out calling it a
psyops so the Russians and the Russian I
believe Ministry of Defense a couple
days ago as soon as these documents came
out said we don't believe them we think
that they're they're being deployed as a
way of tricking us so that was their
initial response to all of this
officially by by the Russian government
but but also a lot of other things came
out from these documents including how
the United States wasn't just
infiltrating and spying on the Russian
government and the Russian military but
also the South Korean military the
Israeli uh military and the Israeli
government as well and there was a lot
of techniques some people argue have
been disclosed here I don't know I
haven't seen that personally myself but
that's the argument we're seeing against
some of these leaks being released that
the number of spies the number and
techniques of how they infiltrated these
institutions was also leaked I haven't
seen that yet but that's some of the
talking points that I'm seeing out there
this this could be a psyop it's worth
pointing out that he's only 21 years old
I mean as whistleblower has come Snowden
was young and he was what 29.
that he this guy Jack would know that
he's going to get done on the Espionage
Act he's thrown his life away and he's a
kid yeah that is that not a tall suspect
how young he is like is that what what's
perhaps or maybe not Young and Reckless
certainly Reckless yeah I wonder if
there is a psyop because think about how
perfect it would be if you want to get
misinformation oh no oh no a leaked
document and then it might like
basically what happens is when they when
the media said some of the information
may be altered may be altered by the
United States so that when it goes out
it's a psyop to manipulate and confuse
the other countries that are involved in
this but but it is interesting to see
the corporate media's response here
because when Donald Trump was President
of the United States when there was
leakers within his administration they
were cheered they were celebrated they
were promoted their story many times was
just reported without even question a
verification sometimes but now we have a
leaker and then the Washington Post and
the New York Times track it down with
bellicat track them down and hunt them
down that that's a big component of the
story that people have been pointing out
that the mainstream media basically
acted like in in like an intelligence
operation extension of the state yep for
the state that is when the government
was like hey who leaked this all of the
news outlets said we're gonna hunt this
person down and figure out who it is but
when it came to Donald Trump's leakers
they were like we must protect
whistleblowers that's the game being
played today man yeah I mean we need
sweeping whistleblower protection reform
I think that that that's a a new type of
legislation that just needs more Focus
that's what we got with uh the arrow
program which is the all domain anomaly
research office for UFO whistleblowers
so now in the ndaa there's there's now
specific protection they're doing an
audit of the whole government for for
UFO related information but the reason
people weren't coming forward before is
because they were they're terrified of
coming forward what was that thing you
guys were talking about who's talking
about this that uh Tucker Carlson said
that whenever troops go like meet Aliens
or whatever their brains melt or
something like Tucker Carlson was on the
full send podcast and he described a
situation where he was looking into a
story where he was hearing of a bunch of
U.S personnel and U.S soldiers that had
interactions with aliens that had
essentially their brains scrambled
um so so again I'm paraphrasing here
from listening to Tucker Carlson Tucker
Carlson explains it a little bit better
but essentially describing how he has
made contact within people who have
verified that there are other entities
out there and when they do get near
human beings they essentially destroy
their mind I would guess that it's more
like that Cuban thing remember they're
doing that like noise weapon or low
frequency Savannah syndrome yes that's
aliens I think it's human I think it's
human technology and they're just
putting chimeric animals if they or or
you know if they think they saw
something that's not human they might be
right but it could be like a part human
you mean the people who think they saw
aliens yeah if they show them if they're
gonna show somebody something and try
and give them a red herring they may be
doing like genetic work on it on animals
and be like look it's from another
planet and then in the background
they've got like vorpal sound just
messing with your DNA and the people are
I don't know about all that but I will
say I think if you believe the US
Military and U.S government is not doing
genetic experimentation and hasn't been
for the past hundred years you are a
crazy person that you guys ever hear of
the humanzy
the story is that uh the Russians here's
here's the crazy thing about the story
chimps so so you can't just hybridize to
like species willy-nilly you have to
actually figure out which which species
has to be the female and which has to be
the male
and I'll tell you the horrifying part
about it
human babies are big chimp babies are
small
chimps have smaller bodies humans have
bigger bodies so when they were doing
these experiments the urban legend tells
that you can't take male parts and put
it into a female chimp because the
female chimp is too small you got to put
the male chimp stuff in the human female
and the human female has to carry the
chimp human hybrid so urban legend is
the Soviets actually
forcefully took women women and made
them do this now I don't know about all
that maybe my point is this
yes the U.S government the Chinese
government they're all doing this stuff
and there was a big story a couple years
ago China is trying to make super
soldiers they are doing human genetic
modification to make
was it Uber mentions is that what it is
like super superhuman Superman yeah
Superman yup that was the Nazi plan I
think was the Ubermensch yep so I I look
if you know I don't know whatever it is
you're talking about because we're
talking about aliens we're talking about
I don't know where all this came
scrambling the brains with vibration
like Havana but I'm into it we're in a
race car just just turning the uh you
made me think of the heart attack the
CIA heart attack gun which we know
exists that that came out in the 70s in
the church yeah so now tell us what they
have now right exactly whenever ever I
hear anything about alien anything I am
I immediately think it's human how could
this be human technology there's there's
so zero to no evidence very little
evidence of any
animal come from another planet there's
none you know my favorite thing about
UFO stories is they tend to take place
near U.S military bases and experimental
research facilities so there's like one
story that was in the press and this one
is blew my mind the story made it to the
press it was like Naval pilot tells
story of strange objects he sees in the
sky and then it's like in the in 2013 he
was flying a routine Mission he brought
the report to his supervisors who said
this is nothing and ignore it and he was
shocked what if this was the Russians
what if it was the Chinese how could
they ignore this report and I was just
like uh-huh maybe it's because they know
what it is and you don't so shut your
mouth and then the best part was the the
sighting was a hundred miles out from a
U.S experimental aircraft facility and
I'm like so basically due to with
limited clearance is doing a routine
exercise and see some experimental
aircraft reports it to his super
commanding officer who's like yeah don't
worry about it and then it's like
they're covering up aliens and it's like
bro that's our base those are our
weapons shut up yeah they have a
technology called super cavitation and
what they do is they mount lasers on the
front of an aircraft and then force them
into each other and shoot this area in
front of the aircraft causing space time
to cavitate and create a vacuum in front
of the plane which draws the plane
forward and causes it not to create a
sonic boom it still makes noise but it
doesn't make Is that real yeah super
capitation what uh this is according to
Jeremy riss who was on Brett Weinstein's
podcast talking about it so there's
technology like that if you see real
craft that sounds like warp drive it's
it's definitely a start towards that
because if you can evacuate space in
front of you you'll be pulled forward
that's a big part of moving through
space well I mean this would that would
only work in an atmosphere this is
mostly the density of that right you
said warping space time
right you're right you're talking about
creating a vacuum in front of you which
causes it's warping pressure thank you
for correcting that it's warping the
atmosphere they may have technology that
works based on I don't know
um and then there's also the idea of
talking plasma which is where they focus
lasers from a distance and they
coordinate them and where they
triangulate it creates like a a ball of
plasma that they can move around really
fast like a laser pointer and they're
probably doing it from space stations
right it's basically just a
three-dimensional laser pointer and we
Chase it around like a cat and so
there's both and it'll confuse people if
they think they're the same thing
they're going to be very confused
because there probably are actual craft
that are able to move
it to be pulled along how did we start
talking about aliens and stuff uh did
Bill you bring it up I probably you
brought him the arrow were you were you
talking with Rogan about it or something
yeah well we were talking about the the
arrow program which is like a
well-funded government program for
researching this now
um and then we also went deep into the
Virginia Brazil incident but I don't
know how deep you guys want to go
where's the incident there's a amazing
documentary that came out earlier this
year called moment of contact by James
Fox
um and it's basically Virginia and
Brazil is basically the Roswell of
Brazil so you know you go there and it's
like huge UFOs it's like Virginia
Virginia
I was like yeah yeah Virginia it's
similar yeah it's weird
um but hundreds of people throughout the
city uh saw objects actually these girls
saw beings apparently and the whole wing
of the hospital had to get demolished
because the smell from this thing
apparently was so bad it infected the
whole building and this is not like the
mayor of the city currently
is took James Fox like all through the
city the mayor of Virginia is like
totally all in on it they have multiple
women when did it happen it happened in
96. wow so there's a lot of
documentation and it is it's either the
biggest
UFO story in history or the greatest
hoax of all time but like the the sheer
number of people who saw the military
checkpoints all over this like you guys
got to watch the document I'm not like
let's do it let's let's go deep next
time after you've all seen it because it
is completely wild I I was I suppose I
don't know why so so bringing it back I
guess if the question was the US real
the US really does have this crazy
advanced technology why aren't they
using it in Ukraine why aren't they
using it in general well is if we have
it it doesn't necessarily mean that we
know how to use it if there's any kind
of recovered materials
you know I mean like the U.S is
developing weapons and stuff because
these wars aren't meant to be won
they're meant to be prolonged um and and
when you continue the war you of course
have so much of a not only profit
incentive but control incentive you have
to understand the the Ukrainian uh
country also controls a lot of the wheat
that's exported all around the world
Russia also when it's being hit with its
sanctions specifically controls a lot of
energy around the world as well so
limiting the amount of energy limiting
the amount of food around the globe is
something that a lot of these top
globalists are really into and and love
having that kind of position of power uh
and and essentially I don't think they
care if if Ukraine wins or loses at the
end of the day especially with how
they're treating them especially with
how they're prolonging this battle now
there's a bunch of black projects
there's a bunch of black budgets there's
a reason and trillions and trillions of
dollars usually goes missing from the
Pentagon every few so years what are
they spending that money on well
probably more ways of destroying the
world but they also know at the same
time we use this latest kind of insane
technological advancement the Russians
will probably use something as well or
the Chinese will use something as well
and they're also developing a lot of
this kind of Doomsday style technology I
mean the Russians are openly talking
about a Poseidon nuclear bomb that will
send a tsunami of nuclear waste towards
uh what they say they have it the
Russians say they have a lot of stuff
doesn't mean they always do they kind of
also talked about how great their latest
tanks were and we really haven't seen
them kind of highlight that in the
battlefield that's happening in Ukraine
so again a lot of this is also saber
rattling a lot of this is also just kind
of posturing so when we look at this
larger perspective and picture
um it is a very complex one but but when
you really look at it yes there is
technology that could kill us whether
it's artificial intelligence whether
it's tsunamis whether it's nuclear bombs
nuclear bomb are still just archaic old
decades uh very very ancient weapons
compared to the latest technological
advancement that they have now what
exactly do we have what do they have who
the hell knows but it's scary and it's
terrible but they're doing all this
including when we look at the realm of
bioweapons that could be used here and
genetically specific weapons that could
be used here especially with so many
governments harvesting people's uh
genetic codes and DNA code have you guys
seen the uh the video of the ship with
the laser on it they point they point
the laser at the Drone and the Drone
burst into flames is it like an
invisible laser it's like a microwave or
something infrared I'm pretty sure so uh
not microwave I don't think that's
that's a laser it's infrared so it's
this gigantic lens and it just points at
the Drone and the Drone just burst into
flames then crashes that's how you beat
drone swarms what kind of are humans
what kind of range can it I think it was
like thousands of feet or something
ridiculous it was nuts and I'm just
wondering if they have that kind of
stuff like they don't use it on people
like imagine if they set that up around
Ukraine they built the these big towers
I guess the issue is electricity if the
power is being cut yeah because if you
have a power source like fusion
generator in addition to that you don't
want to end the war the military
industrial complex maybe wants to
prolong the war you don't want to lose
your most advanced piece of technology
to the enemy just in case if you have
like one or two Fusion powered high beam
Weaponry you don't want to put it in
Ukraine because if someone gets a hold
of that I don't think it's as simple as
you know the we don't want to win the
war I think that there are major
factions of the military industrial
complex contractors and whatnot who have
like a ton of financial interest in the
war but you know a lot of people in the
military I think do want to so there's
it's not black and white thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time